the thing the whole evolution narrative
is the most it's just so hilarious
because the evolution narrative has to
be ends up being teleological they can't
avoid it every time they try to make it
non-teleological
they fail so and so it always ends up
having to be teleological and so
then it then it becomes non-scientific
or immediately it just becomes a kind of
a mythological pattern it's like well if
it's it's mythological story
my mythological story is much better
like the creation narrative in genesis
uh accounts way in a better manner for
the ontological hierarchy of of your
experience of the world than the way
that that that evolution talks about
reality and it's and you can see like i
mean you know when i talked about
weinstein it's always the same issue and
you you see the same with all the
evolutionary theories they're basically
saying what evolutionary want evolution
really wants you to do is to basically
kill and compete and take and
and and just get your seed out there get
your genes to the next generation but of
course we shouldn't do that right it's
like okay well where do you get that we
shouldn't do that from yeah that's
actually what interests me because
that's that's a lot closer to what i
care about and then maybe you can find
that in the genesis story but the other
you can't find it anywhere else in your
little pattern like in your little world
view
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
so i have uh a couple of special guests
with me today on grill country i have
michael martin who's kind of a regular
and a friend of the channel
um dr michael martin you can find on his
own podcast these days regeneration
podcasts where he has very interesting
guests
and uh a guest who will need no
introduction for most of my audience
uh jonathan pajot of the symbolic world
that's great it's great to finally meet
both of you in person i've had contacts
with michael for a long time really at
least 10 years i bet exactly
i sent in a piece of art for his
magazine ones and we met through a
common common friend and so it's great
to see you in person yeah it was nice
well that's great i feel like it for a
long time you know
yeah that's what it feels like too but
we've never actually spoken so yeah
that's actually that's very interesting
because um
like when i first started reading
michael's books it's like that's
immediately it's like oh i need i need
to have him talk to pedro at some point
somehow this got to happen it's like
they've got to talk so here we are
so i might do more listening than
talking today because i'm excited to
hear the two of you talk so um i just
kind of dive in like one thing that we
can like kind of the thing we're going
to talk about today is kind of like
christian esotericism mysticism that
kind of thing and i
and we've been doing this series on um
tonberg's meditation of the tarot
on the tarot on grill country um michael
has um
has taught the book and read it several
times and he's been a guest on some of
her episodes and you've started reading
it recently too
so i thought we could just like maybe
dive into that and tell us about what
your impressions have been of the book
so far
um i really i think it's wonderful there
are obviously a few caveats i was really
surprised about the reincarnation bit i
was like really that's a little
surprising and i know where he gets it i
mean obviously he's a capitalist so he
gets it from the whole cycle of souls
things that's probably where
why he's he's he because he a lot of his
stuff seems to to refer to to a cap to
kabbalah so
um but besides that i think his cosmic
vision is very much aligned with mine
and the way that he understands what he
calls vertical causality he's also
adding some vocabulary for me
that i'll be able to use i think in the
future because it's definitely connected
directly to you know and i think the
richness of the book is also that
i mean this is what we'll get into later
probably in our discussion even with you
michael is that i think one of the
reasons why i've
defecated from kind of christian
esotericism and kind of stepped back
from it is that i i felt like the way
that it was presenting itself to me
especially in the recent
let's say in the last i mean i guess
more like at least 100 years has been
almost as a challenge to christianity
and has been presented almost as
something which was which was subversive
to christianity and i think that when
reading tomber's book i think that he's
really trying to reconcile
you know the the esoteric traditions in
the west with you know real
uh real christianity and and uh and so i
i was really appreciative of that yeah
in a lot of ways it seems like what he's
doing is almost it's almost a plea with
esotericists to cooperate with the
church
it's kind of the tone of like a lot of
the book
definitely i mean i haven't i've read
about maybe a third of the books i i'm
not i'm not right we're near from done
but for sure everything i'm seeing like
i said except for the weird ring
connection reincarnation thing
everything else i i feel is
he's really i think that someone would
read
if someone read that book and then watch
my videos they would immediately
understand what i'm talking about and
probably vice versa like if people watch
my videos and then read that book they
would they would immediately understand
so that's great yeah i think what what
tom berg's
what i think he's doing it resonates
with a lot of people is
there's a kind of traditionalism to him
it's a kind of
uh
not only appreciation but devotion to
traditional sacramental forms of
christianity
and he's right he's a russian
writing in french
about about western esotericism and it's
and it's very different you know i i
don't know maybe i don't know enough
about it
but from what i know
especially the east and especially in
russia
the esoteric traditions if you want to
call them that there were actually
borrowed from the west
yeah from yacob burma and even the
philadelphian society and people like
that and then it then if can we so start
with the protestants
moved to the russians
came back at least part of it came back
to the west but but in the west i mean
you know
part of what i think tom berg's doing
par a lot of what he draws on is not
what i would even call like kind of a
traditional uh
i i i can i
hesitate to use the word uh well
christian hermeticism the word he uses
yeah uh
he he
because his christian hermeticism is
is grounded more in the 19th century
and he went when he quotes all these
authors like lfs levy and papa yeah most
of his sources seem to be like late yeah
like 19th and early 20th century
and yeah
uh um which are all i mean they're all
interesting and pella down in particular
it's kind of fascinating to me
um
but tomber i mean i mean so so my
doctorate is in 16th and 17th century
english or english literature or
religious literature
where
when hermeticism was hermeticism
so it's a very different
it's very different you know that that
strain of hermeticism so when people
talk about rosicrucianism or hermeticism
and they think it's like being a
freemason and like well no no that's how
these
those those kind of people control you
guys though those well the thing is what
happened is
after the 17th century when there was a
kind of a revi revival of that stuff and
it was connected to masonry in the 18th
century 19th century
they kind of just borrowed the
vernacular
and appropriated it and it really
doesn't have a lot to do with with this
kind of uh
because if you look at like traditional
figures from the hermetic
uh period in 17th century england like
robert flood and uh
thomas and henry vaughan and jacob
they were
if you would have we would have talked
to them in right now they would have
described themselves as kind of
traditional christians yeah what they
were rejecting was
the scientific revolution and its
base materialism and which if you can do
science without
the realm of the spirit they thought
that was that was crazy right
and so they were they were kind of
traditionalists they were kind of
you're right there's a way in which it
seems like the freemasons they seem to
have just they basically just want to
aggregate all the esotericism they
seemed at least at some moment maybe not
so much now but at least in the in the
late in the 19th century they seemed to
want to just kind of pull everything
into their sphere and so started using
all this imagery from the different the
different esoteric traditions and so
that's why i think today people also
conflate it all together and because of
also the the strangeness of the the so
you know the the luciferian hoax of uh
that happened with the mason that all
got weirdly kind of brought into
modern occultism and then taken up by
the satanist basically using the the
tech seals host hoax as a as a template
for their satanism it's just it's just
so all of it just so weird that yeah
it's also one of the reasons why i kind
of tend to stay away yeah no kidding i
would too yeah because it just like it
just it's also hard for people to be
able to
differentiate and i also i often feel
like i don't have to like i don't need
it
you know i i i think i feel like i have
insane gregory vanessa and insane
maximus and
in you know a good cosmic understanding
of the liturgy it's like i have
everything i need and and if i'm going
to pull from other sources i can do it
once in a while but i tend not to do it
too much because if i if i would if i do
then people get confused that's my
feeling at least i understand it now you
ever you ever read the book foucault's
pendulum yeah
that's a that's a hilarious book yeah
it's hilarious i really enjoyed it i
thought i read the whole thing as a
giant like kind of joke honestly it is
it is it's
it's set up it's like it's like a
400-page setup to a joke
you know
because
what he does because all the
the the so-called occultists you know
they they get talked into thinking
they're members of a of an occult group
they didn't know existed but they're
sure they're initiates into it
yeah he basically invents an esoteric
society
society and then he it's basically
saying like because it's the idea of the
seat because the idea of the secret is
what rules a lot of these players then
if we create another secret it's it's
almost like creating a body to be
it's like a little vacuum for which
people to kind of step into
i mean you have people today like all
these people saying they're rules of
christians like you've got these rosy
crucian churches in africa there was a
lot of them oh yeah so called roji
christian churches and you have all
these and all these people who think
they're templars they're the same with
the freemasons who think they're
templars and stuff a lot of it i feel is
is so fantastical that i i tend to yeah
but
go ahead sorry no no you're right i mean
they're just appropriating ideas like
i don't think there's any substance
there yeah but see you know like
renegado had i don't know how serious it
was but with papua they had the idea
of creating a kind of christian
esoteric thing using freemasonry the
martinism i think it still exists today
they're still married today and they're
arthur edward wait was another one okay
and
there's some of those people in the
occult revival of the late 19th and
early 20th century i mean some of them
not everybody but some of them tried to
um
christianize it or or try to yeah wait
was a member of the golden dawn at the
same time as charles williams yeah and
but they both bailed on it right and
and uh
so but i but i think you know it's
actually
because i i was puzzling over of this
whole phenomenon
in anticipation of our talk
and thinking about you know
now i'm technically an eastern right
catholic and jonathan is orthodox so
it's pretty much the same thing
um
but there's no tradition like that as
far as i know
in in those romans and i mean they
certainly picked
the the russians for instance would pick
up on freemasonry and all that stuff
after the fact
but there's no kind of there's no
homegrown version right but i think it i
think that the reason why we don't see a
homegrown version is that we don't see
what we could call the we don't see the
split because one of the problems is
that there's a there's a problem there's
a problem with high theory in the world
of esotericism which is that i think
that when people start to create
explicit systems and try to create
things that are very very um
they're almost like these these
that are that are very explicit systems
of of causality and higher beings and
all this stuff i think that that's one
of the issues that happens in western
estudiarism there's almost like a split
between popular
uh
religion that is that becomes more
sentimental and more morality based and
then you have this thing that splits out
and becomes
very high-minded and and intellectual
and esoteric intellectual yeah but i can
find
i can find everything in the icon of the
last judgment that you could find in any
esoteric system that that you could
develop you know in the in the say that
the layout of a church and the way that
it's all set up all it's all there but
it's not necessarily
uh it's not necessarily uh theorized
is what the way that i would say it
and i don't that makes sense no i it
does but the where i was heading pardon
me is uh so i'm preparing for i have to
get this lecture in september
on pavel florinsky yeah the russian
sociologist and priest and murder
and so i was reading some of his earlier
articles he was only in his early 20s
and
a phrase that comes up at least twice
maybe more in
those articles
is the salt has lost its savior
and he was concerned
and he's i think he was already ordained
at this point he was concerned that uh
that the the the experience of
christianity in russia at the time
that
for a lot of people the the salt had
lost its savor there was no flavor to it
and i think
what i in the looking around now and i i
can imagine
what drew
tomberg for instance community because
he grew up in russia
um
or drew
people like arthur edward wade or
whoever it happens to be
toward that stuff is i think lavender is
something to say well blavatsky she's
kind of yeah she's russian too but she's
yeah yeah what's with mention yeah but
but my point is is that and in fact if
you read the the notes of bulgarkov and
uh florensky and florensky's book uh
the pillar and the
what's it called
the the big one you know the pillar yeah
the girl yeah is that pillar and ground
of truth or something yes the pillar and
ground of truth
um
is that they were reading a lot of
people like rudolph steiner and lead
beater they i don't know if they were
quote lavonski but they do those other
people
and or and john portage and jacob burma
so they were in uh
they were definitely
aware of that stuff and i think the
reason being and
let's hear what you guys think about
this
is that like we see right now
with a lot of kids who grow up or people
even adults who grew up in a christian
tradition
and
somehow
the salt loses its savor for them and
they and then they whether they're
they're drawn to buddhism or something
else very exotic or i see a lot of kids
being drawn toward neo-paganism for
instance
and i'm i'm wondering if this is the
same kind of thing that
florensky was seeing in 1903
and that maybe was was impacting those
people in the occult revival of 19th
century
that's that's a good that's a good
theory i think it's an interesting
theory and i think it also it's a you
could say something like it connects to
my own experience which is that for me
my my i never stopped being a christian
i always really stayed a christian but
let's say there was a detour
and then a return where it's like i was
reading more exotic things and stranger
things and then i was able to then look
back at you know
traditional christianity and and find in
it you know the fullness that i that
i've been missing but when i did though
i also left to the side a lot of the
weird stuff that that i might have been
interested because i felt like there was
something about it which was
like i said there's something about it
that was deincarnation like that was
like too high and so it tended to suck
it tended to suck the world towards a a
kind of uh
it's a head trip
yeah
yeah and it and it's not
i think it's also because a lot of
people i met they would they would tend
to use esoteric ideas to relativize
existence constantly to constantly
relativize forms and so they're
constantly criticizing any form and
everything as if you know it's all about
this high high and it's like einstoff as
if it's like as if it's like einstoff
will destroy the world it's not supposed
to be in the world and so you have to be
careful with even with non-dualists you
see it all the time when non-dualists
are out of control they tend to want it
they have this like weird
potion inside them to destroy the world
and to kind of relativize everything to
the point that it that that it actually
and so i think that that's why i tend to
come back and i think incarnational
thinking and that's why like through
certain descent hermeticism has
something i think
possibly to offer and interestingly
enough if according to the information
that i have like whatever remaining
hermeticists that seem to still exist i
mean they just do the jesus prayer now
like that's the i think that maybe they
think that that's all that's really left
of what hermeticism and so they get
together and they do the jesus prayer
and they don't they're not initiating
anybody else it's like the doors oh yeah
there's no one else coming in they're
just gonna die with the with whatever it
is that they have let me initiate you i
will be your master yeah yeah i have no
i had no p i was
my my uh trajectory is kind of very
similar to yours and i got to the point
i was like no i'm not how about i just
bloom where i was planted i'll try that
right which
i mean it's good and you know sometimes
it's good sometimes it's not so good but
uh that's what i what i what i and and
this is what had drew me
towards sociology you know because i i
saw in sociology
you know
this very very much an ecumenical thing
right because there's a
there there were russians who were who
were doing it attracted to it it's a
vladimir slovey of bulgakov lorensky
virgil
but there were also um protestants who
kind of started it off in modern times
uh jaka burma the philadelphian society
uh thomas and henry vaughn for sure
and then
a little bit later it hit the west in in
the catholic west
with louis boye and thomas merton and
and people like this right
so
so to me it seemed
what i would the appeal with that was
not that it was
um fit material for some kind of
esoteric construct but that it was just
very simple
in
in having
the idea that
if if if we're in a right relationship
with god and creation we're we're in a
right relationship
that's and that's in sociology is that
that's enough for me i don't need i
don't need all these
elaborate systems and explanations and
wheels within wheels to figure it out
sorry sorry i'm just going to say it was
interesting you mentioned the ecumenical
piece because bulgakov was particularly
committed to those kind of ecumenical
efforts
um when he was when he was in england he
tried to bring
uh his anglican community that he was
associated with um
in communion with the orthodox church
so he was deeply committed to that kind
of vision
so i i think to me that the whole
you could say that
let's say that the the hyper ecumenical
part and i it comes from i do see how it
is related sociology and that's one of
the reasons why maybe i'm
i am careful about so i tend to if you
listen to my talks you'll notice i talk
about the idea of the secret feminine
for example like i will use i'm afraid
of the explicitation right of the
mystery let's say of the feminine into
the christian the christian story i'm
very scared of that and i feel
like those that have gone too far in
that they tend to fall into
a strange
relativization again of of forms and so
and they get flaky right and they get
they're flaky in this but they move like
it's like i'll give you an example very
practical example my own my own brother
went to a trappist monastery to search
for his own vocation spent a month there
and met with all these thomas merton
like
monks
and he said every single day he would
speak to the his his the supervisor
there he would come to talk to him
spiritual advisor and all that guy would
do was talk about buddhism
really that's all he would talk about he
said he it's like my own brother was
like well what about jesus he's like
yeah of course he'd talk about jesus for
about two minutes and then he go right
back to buddhism and it's like it's that
but there's something about that when i
notice like i've seen with a lot of the
non-dualist and and i'm seeing that with
like someone that like i admire david
bentley heart very much so but i'm
seeing some of that in his even in
sometimes i see him almost have a
disdain for christianity and disdain for
orthodoxy sometimes when he's speaking
it's like it's trite you know let's talk
about shankara and let's talk about all
these other non-dual systems and i'm
like
i don't know how helpful this is
especially in the public in the public
discussion and that's what actually
that's what bothers me about
perennialism
and
you know and those kinds of
traditionalisms which he said well if
everybody's right
what am i doing this for
why am i looking you know because i
don't buy it right because that you know
i figured for me he's like well
the incarnation the crucifixion and the
resurrection that's better that's what i
need right there and i get it right and
that's i'm sticking with that guy right
i'm going that's the god i'm going to
stick with and you know what i mean no i
i of course totally agree with you yeah
you know and uh
objectively it's
the story of christ is unsurmounted like
there's nothing that beats that that
beats that story so it's like it's well
i would say that even the possibility of
perennialism being a view that people
hold
is only because of christ like that's
like i don't think that there's no way
in a pre-christian era you could have
that as a thing that anyone would
think yeah well i think paganism a lot
of paganism is actually pretty
relativistic in that sense you know so
the ancient pagans usually would would
they had like in the back of their minds
a map a cosmic map and then they would
map on
to the different cultures that they
would encounter and so you can read in
ancient greek and roman texts like you
know oh they worshipped this god those
yeah they were right it would map on
their gods to the other gods not the
romans the gods onto the german gods
right and so on yeah and you see the
same like i think indian systems like
advaita they tend to be quite
they tend to be quite relativistic in
terms of understanding that this kind of
manifests itself everywhere like all the
pattern that they believe in is
basically
in every culture yeah on the other hand
i think it is i mean not for everybody i
mean it's not everybody's thing but but
the study of comparative religion and
what's beautiful in other religions is
really a worthwhile activity right
which is what i don't know about you but
that's basically what i was doing after
from the age of 18 till about 28 or so
you know so i was just checking it out i
mean i like you i never didn't feel like
i was a christian
you know never not ever
you know yeah i tend i tend to really
see now like my approach to comparative
religion is really a
like well i guess i like like what what
nate was saying it's really is christ
center that is i tend to see everything
through the lens of the incarnation and
then
then i'm able to look at at other
traditions without feeling either
overwhelmed or threatened or whatever i
just see it as glimmers and and
manifestations of the the incarnational
principle um and so so in that sense i
don't i never feel like i'm in danger of
being overwhelmed by all these other
traditions and i also so i feel like i
would never participate in like in other
religious rituals uh you know i i only
participate in christian christian
tradition but i can read a sufi poem and
i find it beautiful and insightful and
extremely connected
to to something which i see in the
church fathers as well right and it's
interesting that you know in in toperg
two things he says on this this topic he
says uh
you know
while who came before me were beggars
and thieves
right meaning
all the religions that came before were
beggars and thieves and the other thing
is
behold i make all things new
so
how how
those different systems we could say
and this is what i think tomber is
trying to do in his book are
and this is what actually hans von
balthazar said about solovia is that he
that sloviev took all these
you know gnostic systems and other
things and he ran them through
christ as in appear as through a
purifying stream right and i think
that's part of what tomberg's project is
in that book
is
to to clean it up
you know
yeah
right christianity did that with plato
did it with the highness you know and so
i think
and he's giving people of that esoteric
event a way back in
i remember when i read the book i said
wow
in my father's house there are many
mansions because what my problem was
before that is i thought i had a very
limited
perception and understanding of what
christianity is
and i read that book i said wow maybe i
didn't give this thing enough credit
at the catholic church maybe it didn't
give it enough credit maybe i didn't i
could i was too busy seeing the version
i got in the suburbs of detroit in a in
a second-rate catholic school
and not
what's really there
yeah but that's actually one of my
arguments for christianity really has
been its integrative
possibility because one of the things
that i see also in that's what i called
i don't know what to call it like the
esoteric split that happened you know at
the renaissance or after a bit after the
renaissance is that they're you can see
how things
how these these elaborate and very
intellectual systems kind of move up and
then you can notice religion becoming
more and more sentimental and moralistic
and
and less and less
understood you could say and so but i
think that what christianity ultimately
offers is a way all
it should be a way all the way through
so it's like when you stand in a church
and you have this
painted system of images right
it's connected to a simple person could
go in there and be completely touched
and and impressed but then you know a
metaphysician will walk in and see the
map of the universe in the church so i
think that that's one of the reasons why
i that's one of the reasons why i i tend
to to to stay within let's say the more
traditional
the to talk about the church fathers as
much as saying i mean truth the church
fathers right it's like it's it's it's
always the same sign from saying gregory
said maximus
so you know and they they seem to have
had all those intuitions that that uh
that are in the best of the esoteric
systems let's say
well and that that's and that's what i
think you know another
we were talking earlier about why people
feel
sometimes the salt is lost in savor
and this is my own experience growing up
you know i was kind of just naturally
interested in
mysticism as i mean i went to catholic
school and you know i wanted to know
this person talked to jesus or the
virgin mary what'd they say what was it
like how did that how does that happen
and nobody wanted to tell me
you know because and i think
um
so what i got instead was you know the
catechism
or
kind of a dry intellectual delivery we
had the baltimore catechism it was i
think that's turned more people off
chris of the catholic church than the
sex scandal
but but
and
and so it was
for me certainly i mean
for a lot of people it was an
unincarnated
experience of christianity which is
which is ironic right
because
and
how how do you return to that and i
actually most of my life has been trying
to
find a way back into the to that
incarnated experience of christianity
yeah and i mean i see all your just your
daily practices of being a farmer and
doing that i can see when i when i kind
of follow you and see what you're doing
i can notice that you're really trying
to find that
that lived let's say
incarnational principle yeah
and i don't want to read about it you
know what i mean
well yeah you know because i think what
happened after that split you talked
about in the renaissance of the
reformation
is
at least in the west
not only did religion become more and
more sentimental
but on the other half of it it became
aridly intellectual
yeah you know parts of it may not be
active
right
and
and so
and it was in fact it was reading in uh
florensky it was he was talking about uh
the russian tradition which is what i
love about it is it's both intellectual
and
anti-rational at the same time you know
it's very intuitive or mystical while
it's being intellectual which is
you know you see that
probably in slovey of more than anybody
you know who's who who is the model for
both
yvonne and elijah in the brothers
karamazov oh really i didn't know that
that's interesting yeah that's it
actually it's it's in a book written by
his nephew
that he meant
that yeah because uh because dostoevsky
was good friends with sloviev okay yeah
and he based to hit those two brothers
on his two sides
that's hilarious his
intellectual side it is in his
deeply intuitive and warm side
yeah that's really fascinating so what
do you think about like let's say the
basic perception that i have which is
so let me give you let me give a very
practical example about what i'm talking
about and so you know especially this is
this is interesting because the georgia
guidestones were destroyed right just a
few weeks ago or whatever last week and
so you know according to the the the
legend the person who had it built was
named christian r.c and
so you could say so like in a way it
doesn't matter like whether or not this
is related to any group that is actually
considering themselves rosicrucian it's
there is something about the the
branding there's something about the
fact that
normal christians wouldn't
refer to the rosy cruciates but right
now something like weird anti-human
uh esoteric like kind of occultist type
thinking will attribute themselves to
the rosy cruciations we can say like
it's it's too bad or whatever but
there's something about that which i
think is
is important to understand in terms of
this split that i talk about where and
and the let's say the accumulation of
this esoteric tendency into let's say
freemasonry groups or whatever like
trying to capture and blavatsky was also
was also kind of trying to pull whatever
she could from all that stuff and so
this is i think so it's like although i
could i can for example in rob someone
like robert flood i can see let's say
the power and the the good intentions
that are there and this desire to to
keep something magical and and and and
wonderful about christianity it's like
by the time you get to crowley it's like
yeah and all these people are seeing
themselves in line with that same that
same type of thinking i'm like
something's off like something really
went off absolutely and i need to i need
to not be too associated with whatever
that is no you're right and and
so my doctorate i did my dissertation
um
one of the chapters is on it's kind in
fact the title is the rosicrucian
mysticism of thomas and henry vaughan
because they were part of that initial
17th century movement but if you and the
the original documents of the rose of
christians were written by a lutheran
pastor
and if you read them
they're
as straightforward uh christianity as
you can get
you know it's they were they were just
interested in
the
the rebuilding of society and some
people tried to say that they wanted to
rebuild society in the scientific way
which is not true at all
um now what's your name uh francis yates
wrote a book the rosicrucian
enlightenment i think she she totally
misunderstood what was going on it was
actually like i said earlier a kind of a
traditionalist movement that didn't want
to lose
that
um traditional western christian
understanding of the relationship the
microcosm to the macrocosm
about
god's presence in the world about the
presence of not angels and demons in the
world right yeah as is contributing to
even weather patterns right
um which was all thrown out the window
with renee descartes
and and they were in fact they they they
would rip on the cart in their books
they didn't like him at all
letter trying to be initiated into the
room yes he did yes he did
they turned him down good choice yeah
i would have turned him down too
i'm not answering that call
but uh but it's funny because you read
that and
so when i think of rosicrucianism i
automatically think of that stuff yeah
which is
i mean when you read it you can't see
how anybody could interpret it otherwise
but then you look at the crowley stuff
and the the golden dawn and that came
much later and as we said earlier this
these appropriations of the term
in fact even the idea that the rose
cross there and i think it's a good
argument that that the rose cross comes
from the coat of arms of martin luther
which had a cross and a rose on it yeah
you know
so who could be some people think the rc
means roman catholic you know there was
a lot of discussion in the 17th century
about whether this is actually the
jesuits trying to get protestants to
come back into the fold
yeah jesus
you know the jesuits right they were
smarter than everybody but
but i still i mean yeah so how does it
get from there
to to what it became in the 19th century
it's just or even the 18th century it's
so strange but i think it's i think we
have to we really have to understand it
as as is the incarnation it's like we
often think of something which becomes
decadent as always going too low but it
it actually always starts with going too
high it's like there's pride pride is
the first sin and so there's something
about trying and you can see it like in
the very rituals of the early uh
occultists and you know the the early
magicians and the demonologists there's
something very
powerful pride in that the very idea of
let's say weaponizing or capturing the
spiritual entities and inquiring from
them or using them for to to manifest
their will it's like that is some that
is definitely
something which
i think represents that pride which we
then
though maybe it you all do it for the
good reasons at the beginning right it's
like you know we're going to do this to
help the world we're going to we're
going to capture these demons in order
to in order to understand them and then
exercise them from society it's like
that leads very quickly in my opinion
absolutely i agree i totally agree
and i and that's what i i think uh well
like like in fact in my dissertation the
first chapter is on john d
who was pr who was doing that precisely
and who got played like a game of
yahtzee by the by the speaker
yeah by these yeah
they worked him man
and he and he that thing is he was he
was a good man i think yeah you know he
was like he's a guy who loved his family
loved his country was you know doing all
the right stuff but as you said his
problem was
his pride
you know i am the one who will bring
this to the world
and he thought that he was going to
recover the language of adam and that
would heal all the divisions in
christendom
you know
wrong yeah exactly
and of course the spirits talk him and
and his assistant to swapping their
wives right yeah yeah which is mean you
don't get any more mortal soon than that
right
it doesn't it doesn't get better after
that let's just do them all yeah let's
just get on it doesn't get better after
that it's like
but but i think but on the other hand
you look at
henry vaughn and his and his brother and
there's a i mean especially in henry
there's such a beautiful
practical spirituality in his poetry
that's both connected to nature and to
god
and to scripture i mean it's i remember
when i when i so doing a dissertation
you have to read everything the person
wrote so i was reading
oh all this guy wrote and i'm
done oh yeah this is basically what i am
this is what i am this is my
spirituality right here which is very
simple it's not complicated and it's not
a cult in the least
it's very
but it's very mystical i would say in in
a
in a practical mystical way yeah you
know just not you know not a pr
hopefully not a prideful one but
you know
what's important
god
his creation
and community right the church would
call the community of the church
and that
i think from um
you know if you focus on what's
important
then then you know then you protect
yourself hopefully from
a little bit of evil
yeah well definitely i think i mean i
think that that's also so i don't know
if you've noticed like there's an
interesting moment right now it's it's
just interesting because
it seems like
something got broken i guess in the past
10 years i don't know how to say it
something broke and and all of a sudden
secular atheists and secular people are
now able to perceive
principalities and they're able to
understand at least what it is that
we're even talking about when we use the
word angel so it's an interesting moment
uh but it's also in some ways a very
dangerous moment and that's something
that i sometimes don't emphasize enough
especially with the psychedelics a lot
of people taking psychedelics and they
indiscriminately encounter beings and
then they're all excited about whatever
it is that they encounter uh and so
i don't know if you've noticed that it
seems like there's that we're at a at a
like a
a moment where magic seems to be seeping
back into the world uh but it's not all
positive like it's which is weird
because it that's seeping in while at
the same time well where everything's
becoming
disenchanted through the internet right
yeah there's this weird polarity going
on right but it seems to be like it's
almost as if it's almost as if a natural
movement of moving so far into darkness
that all of a sudden like you know these
small lights start to be visible and
people start to
to see and also this also because
because we're noticing i think one of
the things that's doing it is actually
the internet because the internet is
based on attention
and it's actually bringing to the fore
the function of attention in the way the
world lays itself out and so it's like
there's not much more there's not like
that's what magic is like magic is about
that and so if you understand that and
so and now people have that experience
where they're noticing how there's
everything is vying for their attention
and that attention is actually creating
bodies of
of interest and and is actually kind of
transforming reality so i think that
there's a strange and because it's
accelerated online right it's usually
these cycles of interest are long and
they they don't they don't last like two
days or one week or sometimes one day
you know this idea of something trending
you know and so i think that there's
something about that which is making
people notice
something like the vertical causality
that tomburg talks about that is that
there's a relationship between
yeah that there's raising between like
common attention and then things
manifesting themselves let's say yeah
right
agrigore
yeah well yeah that's what a lot of us
are trying to like yeah talk about and
try to help people differentiate the
different the different uh
but i'm even even as i'm doing that i'm
worried because like i meet people that
are like all excited they're like like
you talk about these angels i want to
meet them like what no no that's not but
that's not why we're doing this like
we're doing this so that people can see
through let's say at least understand
this this hierarchy of principality so
they can see incarnationally but it's
not about like having it try to have
encounters with angels it's usually not
the good angels they don't they don't
want to talk to you that way
that's right i used to like tell people
very back in the day my students would
say i'm gonna mr martin i'm gonna use
the ouija board like no no no no no why
because because it's like dialing seven
numbers and saying can i talk to jesus
yeah and the demon says
he thinks it's jesus yeah
jesus speaking you know what i mean
you're asking for trouble
because they're smarter than you and
they're and they'll like with john d
they'll they'll play you like a game of
yahtzee
they'll just mess you know what i mean
they'll just
ridicule you and that's one of
tom burke actually talks about that how
they just they lead people along yeah
you're you're special
come on and we'll give you all this
information which is all just
ends up being gobbledygook
yeah and you see it like you if you've
known like i usually see it a lot of the
people that are around me that are
interested in kind of new age stuff and
get sucked into that then they all have
their weird guardian angels and their
weird guides and stuff and it's usually
never ends well like it just never it
doesn't go well never ever
oh man so nate so what is it that you
want us to talk about besides the thing
we talked about already
you guys seem to have no problem
there are things that you're curious
about because i because because because
i also wanted this to be there's there's
one there's a couple one one thing you
said early on i just
it's interesting the way thomberg
actually approaches the subject of
reincarnation because he just says
either you've experienced it or you
haven't
and he doesn't argue he doesn't he
doesn't argue for the fact he argues he
can't argue right exactly and he doesn't
any and he doesn't make any argument for
it being a meaningful part of a
spiritual system of any kind
it's just kind of like and then he and
he drops it after that so the way he
presents it is weird so i'm wondering
what you thought of that and then
in letters i don't i don't know if you
got into letter six yet but this idea of
of of evolution being like on the
horizontal plane
[Music]
under the guise of the serpents
that was very interesting to me because
um
i can remember when i i was raised
pentecostal
and i can remember when i was going
through my catechism when i was
converting to catholicism i still like
had some misgivings about evolution
and i thought and and i made it
to my priest about how you really can't
if evolution is absolutely true without
any qualification there's no resolution
to the problem of evil possible because
you can't really
there's no way of dealing with the
physical evil yeah so i thought the way
that tom burke talks about evolution
as being this groping trial of the
serpent
offers a way to do that
i tend to
i like the way that i i i presented
before and the way i present it now is
that i think natural selection is a
pattern in the world it's a true pattern
and it's a pattern that can help you
understand things but i think the
narrative evolution is just
useless and not interesting and and it
doesn't help you do anything like it
it's a it's a it's a it's it's it has to
be it always ends up having to be
represented mythologically despite the
scientists pretending that it's not and
it's what
though because he says he says it's a
fact right so it's a fact on the
horizontal plane it's a fact
but it's a fact only it's a fact only on
the horizontal plane
and that its guide and that
because it's on the horizontal plane
it's its origin is the serpent
but you know i i think um
part you know thomberg was a man of
his time
and
that was the language that was
the language of evolution was which was
appropriated by blavatsky
and the early steiner also picked up on
it and they were speaking in these kinds
of terms now it's spiritual evolution
right
um now my friend guido preparato
he's kind of he's a blunt and funny guy
and he thinks
darwin's whole project was was just uh
a project to
prove british imperialism
you know it was social dark you know
what we call a social downwards
darwinism now yeah that's what it is see
there's survival of the fittest the
british are the fittest end of story
right
um so i don't buy i mean personally
the i i don't know what to think of the
evolution narrative i mean i'm sure
things do i'm a farmer i know
how things work but of course
we we have we have a society that
believes in evolution but doesn't
believe in gender it's a fig i can't
figure it out
you know
what's wrong
it's also the the thing the whole
evolution narrative is the most it's
just so hilarious because the evolution
narrative has to be ends up being
teleological they can't avoid it every
time they try to make it
non-teleological
they fail so and so it always ends up
having to be teleological and so
it then it then it becomes
non-scientific
immediately it just becomes a kind of a
mythological pattern it's like well if
it's it's mythological story
my mythological story is much better
like the creation narrative in genesis
accounts way in a better manner for the
ontological hierarchy of your experience
of the world than the way that that that
evolution talks about reality and it's
and you can see like i mean you know
when i talked about weinstein it's
always the same issue and you you see
the same with all the evolutionary
theories they're basically saying what
evolutionary want evolution really wants
you to do is to basically kill and
compete and take and
and and just get your seat out there get
your jeans to the next generation but of
course we shouldn't do that right it's
like okay well where do you get that we
shouldn't do that from yeah that's
actually what interests me because
that's that's a lot closer to what i
care about and then maybe you can find
that in the genesis story but the other
you can't find it anywhere else in your
little pattern like in your little world
view well you know who believes in the
evolution story the world economic forum
yeah
and guess who's at the top of that food
chain um
but you know it's interesting because
you think about you mentioned genesis
genesis is the opposite
of the evolution it's the fall yeah
right it goes in the opposite direction
yeah i mean it been and you're right but
you can you can understand
you can you can understand
it's it's so much closer to even to the
way that evolutionists think of of their
their teleological project because there
is a hierarchy of being if you read
saint ephraim it's it's beautiful like
san fran says that he says things like
the animals did not come into the garden
right and so the animals were would come
to the foot of the garden then adam
would come down the mountain and he
would like encounter them and that's
when you name them and everything so
there's this sense in which like the the
type of ontological hierarchy that they
tried to create in their evolutionary
system it's it's it's there in the more
traditional narrative and it's more
it's actually accounts for morality and
responsibility and all this stuff that
we actually think even now even all
these weird environmentalists like super
environmentalists they're they they
believe in what genesis says like they
believe that we're the gardeners and we
should take care of creation and that we
shouldn't abuse and it's like if you're
really like just an evolutionist i don't
know if you could really believe any of
those things
that's what that's what happened with
and i think that's uh explains tom
berg's attraction for taylor de chedan
right
yeah because that's that's evolution
taken into catholic theology yeah i
haven't gotten there and so maybe i'll
definitely have my my beef with him when
he gets to the other side there i don't
know yet well like i don't know if you
read taylor i mean he's a beautiful
writer
he really is a he writes like a poet
yeah
and uh it's beautiful writing and he has
a lot of brilliant insights i think
um
the the complete project
i don't have to believe agree with with
people about everything that they'd say
of course you're right i don't like them
i'm just i'm just i'm cool with the
parts i like you know
i don't have to i don't have to be all
in
yeah no i totally agree with that i
actually agree with that that's how i
approach pretty much everything
i don't it's like i don't have to defend
everything that this person that i yeah
you know slightly associated with says
i don't agree with everything my wife
says
you know
so well what about some guy never met
right you're gonna tag me with
everything he ever thought or believed
yeah definitely definitely
don't tell her that
she says don't tell them
i'm sure she knows i'm just you know
she says yes
and so i mean like for me i think that
the ultimately for me the the solution
that i've been trying to to propose has
really been
the the taking the traditional forms
that are there taking the liturgical
life that is that has all the potential
like i said like even if it's lost it's
like if it's lost it's salt it's like
it's there it just has to be it has to
be kind of re recaptured and relived and
so
to me that seems like the only really
realistic solution and and in it
well one of the things that florensky
mentioned in there which
which kind of added savor to it was uh
those kinds of folk traditions yeah you
know that
you know are they chris really christian
are they kind of christian but yeah
let's keep those in there because
those
those those make christianity a way of
life and not something you do on sunday
right and try to think you know i say a
couple prayers during the day but how do
you incorporate that into a lived life
right yeah definitely because we people
tend to think
modern people tend to think more
monastically it's like they think that
you know living a more kind of embodied
christian life would mean to just have
you know do the hours or whatever do
more more services but i think you're
right that there's a there's a more
there's an even more embodied way which
is if you think of the middle ages and
they had all these associations and
clubs and people would you know be in
the association of this saint and they
would have their costumes and they would
have all the stuff and they would have
you know like all these banners and
processions and stuff it's hard for us
to even imagine it but i know it's still
with my friend andrew gould i remember
he said he went to this little village
in spain and and he said it was just
astounding they had these four hour five
hour processions of their statue of the
mother of god you know all dressed up
and and everybody had these like
particular costumes and they would just
kind of walk around
and and every and he said he was so
solemn and it lasted forever but
everybody was just completely enthralled
by these processions
and so yeah it's just hard because we
don't in north america
it always feels like we're immediate but
it always feels like we lost like so
much of it that to bring it back is
almost idiosyncratic you know yeah i
mean and i say that for the orthodox
very much it's like it's like people
become orthodox and they think they'll
immediately become russian or it's like
that's not going to happen right you
have to find some kind of discussion
about how to embody
folk
folk traditions right so let's say on
for us on on theophany like we'll still
do like for a traditional french
epiphany uh celebration right we have a
cake and we like baking in it yeah we do
it and we have like the king of the day
and stuff and so like this is not
orthodox but it's it's like these are
the traditions that we have it's french
canadian yeah yeah it's definitely
french canadian that's right yeah yeah
we do we need to like find ways to
connect all this in a way that is that
it's going to be messy and organic but
it was so already
in the focus kind of already the norm
orthodoxy though it's a kind of like
morph itself somewhat to the culture
that
that it's expressed in it should
hopefully well the greeks have a lot of
you know the other thing that
like like the the bean cake and you know
all that stuff
um
i also think that's
a way to to have
children
this is a way to raise children in a
lived experience of
christianity you know because they they
can they're not gonna
you know we all remember being in church
is those little kids listening to a
sermon i mean not listening to a certain
and wondering how long is this gonna
take
right
but
that those those festivals of
conviviality
make it for for children and for growing
people too
uh a lived experience and then when
people have children
they want they want they you can people
hunger for that yeah they want an
experience of of the world
that is
that is
not only spiritually nourishing but
that's nourishes their their souls and
their relationship with other people
because you can do it by yourself right
there's something different when you do
in a community yeah which is what a
church is supposed to be
and i think so i think that's why i mean
i've noticed a lot of these orthodox
churches take it seriously is to realize
how the coffee hour in terms of in terms
of a modern church is absolutely
essential that you actually you really
need to have
one or two hours after liturgy or after
a service for people to be together
because we're not in a village anymore
you don't just walk out and then go back
your house and then it's your neighbor
that was there in church with you so we
have to create these spaces where we we
can have you know a more informal
communion or else it's just gonna
it's not going to it's not gonna it's
not going to go otherwise it's like
punching a clock yeah
trick okay yeah going to the g go
communion go back home okay
bad coffee is important check
but we really noticed like we've noticed
that at least in my parish it's been
it's been one of the because we are
seeing our parents grow quite a bit in
the last year i think a lot of a lot of
parishes are growing because of
postcovid people looking for meaning and
stuff yeah um and we've noticed that
that's been one of the keys has been to
have like a a place and a time
afterwards for people to to sit down and
to connect and so then it encourages
them to to call each other during the
week and to to connect in in in other
informal ways so
yeah so you're right so we need these
more embodied
is more embodied practices yeah because
liturgy is wonderful but it's it's not
it has to kind of seep into all of
reality you can't just yeah it's gotta
be everywhere yeah
nice
yeah
so i mean how does that play in too i
know i know michael you've expressed
some disappointment with the way that
the church handled
kovid
i have and how and i mean it seems to me
that what you guys are talking about
right now and the way the churches kind
of handle kobud
they're not i think i honestly think
like seriously think that covid was a
litmus test for a lot of churches and i
i think that a lot of the churches that
that didn't that weren't attentive to
what was happening and didn't take into
account the the the primacy of communion
i think there a lot of them won't get
over this
i really believe that they just won't
survive and i think the opposite is also
true the churches that that that you
know were a lot of them were cautious at
the outset like where you know obviously
but then slowly started to realize that
okay wait a minute there's something
else going on and then started to to
emphasize communion over
being strict on the rules and everything
i think those will thrive and they have
thrived well yeah one and i just it was
so
for me it was so profoundly discouraging
to see
so many especially in the catholic
church when the pope
um required all employees of the vatican
to have the vaccination like okay
and then no they backed up they never
apologize when they back off it's like
oh yeah well we were
you know it just it's it becomes uh
they're slaves to policy and
and and if you probably saw too there
were many churches across north america
and australia places
who
would have signs saying fully vaccinated
parishioners may come to confession or
to communion right imagine that i mean
we had
like we because you i don't know if you
know what happened here in quebec like
it was crazy because oh yeah yeah so we
we had the church were close which is
the longest time right and then finally
they were open with limited people
whatever blah blah blah and all this
stuff right but then came the moment
when they were gonna they were gonna
impose the covet vaccine passport on the
churches
that was to me that was i think with the
test and those churches that tried to
find solutions to that and not
not impose it because the uh you would
have to have a parishioner standing at
the door with their phone
scanning people as they walked into the
church can you imagine no how crazy that
is and so it's like i think that and the
doors the doors right
that's what that was for right when they
see the doors of doors it was to keep
the you know the spies out look at this
yeah
so they'll come in here and kill us
after we say the creed
yeah exactly and so so i think that i've
seen like the church some churches did
crazy stuff like they had it was minus
30 right it was like right in the we was
like in december in january so some
churches just had services outside you
know people found ways to to get around
it or whatever um but i think the
churches that applied it
that is not a lot of hope for those guys
i'm sorry to say
maybe they'll survive like but i don't
think i think it's going to be a serious
they're going to have to do it with a
lot of like repentance and and return to
and uh and deliberate desire to to to
re-enter communion because yeah well and
i think we'll also see
uh a kind of church of the catacombs
yeah for sure you know
under kind of a
guerrilla church or underground church
or something
you know yeah and people love to learn
to do like we
we we started to learn to do this the
the reader services you know because
it's like if if we if we depend on the
clergy completely then we're
we're we're going to be in trouble
that was i was up i don't know well you
brought a solo viov several times uh
michael and i can't help but think of
tale of the antichrist it's not the
it's the majority of the
church goes along
yeah with the antichrist in that story
it's just like the three figures that he
has representing the you know the
protestant the cat the the catholic and
the orthodox tradition they're the ones
with the courage to stand up but
those major the vast majority of the
clergy
in in all three
go
yep
along
join the antichrist
well it's not hard to it's not hard to
see it now like it's
there's there's something wonderful
about the moment right now which is that
there's a lot of stuff
there's a lot of let's say apocalyptic
thinking that i didn't totally
understand let's say 20 years ago and
i'm not saying that this is it like this
is the end of the world or whatever but
i think that there's a lot of
there's a lot of structure that i can
now see and not only do i understand but
i can see them burgeoning you can kind
of see them
popping up in the world and it's like
okay i understand what is talking about
it's a revelation yeah apocalypse in
that sense it's it's taking it's tearing
the veil open yeah so you can see it
what's
also like the idea of antichrist itself
like the idea of something which is a
parasite on christian morality
but manifests itself so it's like right
the idea for example that we saw like
the weaponizing of compassion that we
saw during the the colgate like that was
like a weird parasite on christianity so
you can kind of see like okay i can kind
of i mean i'm not saying this is
antichrist but i can kind of see the
pattern of antichrist how it can
manifest itself and how it can also
delude people okay how can how it can
trick people into believing this is true
christianity and tricking is the right
word right
yeah and you can see like it's you can
see like with even with like the you can
who would have thought that so for
example like it's like in the abortion
debate i'm sorry to become politically
but like who would have thought that
there would be a common moment when
someone would be able to say out loud
publicly
a christian should be pro-abortion it is
the christian position to yeah this is
the compassionate christian position to
have super abortion it's like and you
see it now people take that position all
the time it's like really it's like who
would have thought but then you can see
it it's a weaponizing of compassion and
and
and the weaponizing of the idea that
we're in the image of god like all of
these christian ideas are being twisted
and and contorted to to bring about
these strange positions yeah
that's all
yeah okay guys i'm depressed now that's
right i'm sorry
okay
but i think like i did like i i'm i'm a
50 50 all the time like this is why i
think i how i survived got 50 50 all the
time because on the one hand i can kind
of see
i can i like all of a sudden i see these
patterns of that are straight up from
the book of revelation kind of come come
towards me and at the same time i'm also
seeing
the the the candle
like being lit i can see like the next
i don't know what to say like i can get
a glimmer of the resurrection it's maybe
there's another way to say it i can see
it like i can actually see it and i can
notice
you know i had this talk with someone
like ian mcgill chris that i think i put
up today i had to talk with don hoffman
all these like cognitive science type
people that are total seculars or even
my discussion with john vicki like
and then we're using the word angel and
demon as if this was a totally normal
technical word to use to talk about
transparent beings and i was like i
can't believe that we're that we've
reached this point where a scientist
would use that word and not flinch or
not feel embarrassed at all about using
it so i think so i think we're we're
going to be surprised like there's going
to be some wonderful
surprises and some dark surprises at the
same time well i think so too and that's
you know and i kind of saw it coming
and
wrote about it you know because i think
you know
like you're saying
we have the rise of the technocracy or
the archons if you want to call them
that yeah but
you know there is also
you know the real possibility
to
uh to live the kingdom
you know
that the kingdom of heaven is within you
you know so there's there's a there's a
capacity to realize that
and i think
and if you go back to the early
christians there were there were those
there were parallel societies there too
parallel opposes right there was there
was the power structure and there was
the kingdom
and
i don't think we've we've had
uh
an enough awareness of the kingdom for
the past couple of few generations
you know and
and i think part of what i think
happened if you read uh
world war ii or post world war ii
literature when all the intellectuals
were like what the heck just what
happened you know what i mean they're
they're soul-searching
and i think that really destroyed a lot
of people as far as as religion goes not
just christianity
you know that the holocaust could happen
and
you could have that much evil and god
didn't intervene right
and i think we we have it at a different
different manifestation of that kind of
evil right now
um but maybe in a way
this is our opportunity
to not despair
has happened to those people in the
1940s and 50s right are they despaired
and it's and it's really easy to despair
yeah
right
well no from listen from listening to my
wife i would say that like the the
jewish experience in that post holocaust
is almost like the opposite though like
there was a lot of like a lot of jews
who weren't really even religious
like they returned to judaism not even
out of any real religious commitment
just out of the idea that there should
be more jews in the world
because like both their parents like
were basically atheists
um but they made sure that their
children were
were raised the knowledge of their faith
and
and practiced anyway
so yeah i mean i think for sure like the
the rise of of the the the hasidim is
based like in part in like the world war
ii and and like the the the return of
kind of orthodox judaism or the strength
of orthodox judaism does it does seem to
be but i think it it's not like i think
what
it's it's it's the two extremes you
could say because also i mean the the
the secular jew is is extremely powerful
in the world right now as well like you
have a lot of that a lot of that very
strong so i think i think we're probably
going to see something similar
in the christian church we're going to
see a kind of remnant which will which
will consolidate and become
you know deliberate and authentic and at
the same time we're going to see the
world in general become more and more
anti-anti-christian and uh and secular
so
i think so
i mean especially as the church is like
here in quebec like the churches are
at some point they're going to start to
demolish the churches like they have to
because they're trying to pas they're
trying to to send these things out
they're trying to sell them but it's
like all these old buildings no one
wants to keep up and so at some point
we're going to start to see bulldozers
like go into these things
it's going to be inevitable we see it in
europe happening now all the time and so
and so i think that that'll have
that'll be important like i think it's
it's probably good that that happens
because it's going to help people
see what's going on
in ways that might
both increase the secularism but also
shock some people into saying okay so
what what is it then it's like is it
more shopping malls is that what we
really need or you know is it
howler cell towers is that is that going
to be like our is that going to be our
our holy place is it going to be really
really tall cell towers but
right
yeah
let's see
sorry michael i feel like i'm really not
oh no no no you're not bumming me out no
no i i agree you know i'm just
just
you know in fact you know
my gosh my whole project is pretty
it's a pretty hopeful project right but
but knowing you're up against this kind
of darkness
yeah
and which is what what surprised me over
the last couple years is how
effective the mass formation and uh
propaganda project of the bad guys has
been i mean
you got to tip your hat it was well
orchestrated
yep
that you could but
but
and
it's a but it's it's it's amazing like
here in canada it's amazing it's amazing
i mean justin justin you know it's just
obviously
like a empty like puppet yeah but it
doesn't matter like it just doesn't
matter it all it all works like at all
the whole world is like that right now
the whole west well it's amazing how
many sophisticated people show for it i
mean just fall for it though i mean it's
it's it's really it's mind-boggling
yeah i mean it's kind of like it
kind of proves a little idea that elites
are more prone to propaganda
oh yeah
well no the propaganda's never aimed at
you know
people with a high school education may
always aim propaganda at the middle
managers the teachers professors and
doctors and people like that who think
they're smart
you're smart because you believe yes i'm
smart and i'm doing this to help others
so you're saying it's designed
specifically for dumb smart people
yeah the midwifes
they're the problem they're always a
problem
yeah
gosh
wow well it was really great getting to
listen to you guys talk i'm glad i'm
glad i brought you to have this
conversation yeah so you got me to be
quiet for the most part which is not an
easy task
it was our plan we talked ahead of time
yeah
well good excellent collusion then okay
all right well well thanks for the
conversation
yeah thanks for thanks for joining me
today i really appreciate the gift of
your time both of you
all right appreciate this i'll i'll let
you know when i get it posted all right
all right great wonderful yep take care
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your
usual podcast platform but we also have
a website with a blog and several very
interesting articles by very intelligent
people that have been thinking about
symbolism on all kinds of subjects we
also have a clips channel a facebook
group you know there's a whole lot of
ways that you can get more involved in
the exploration and the discussion of
symbolism don't forget that my brother
matsuya wrote a book called the language
of creation which is a very powerful
synthesis of a lot of the ideas that
explore and so please go ahead and
explore this world you can also
participate by you know buying things
that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos
through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and uh thank
you for your support